This lecture is about a specific
technique for contextual text mining
called contextual probabilistic latent
semantic analysis.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing contextual text
mining.
And we're going to introduce contextual
probabilistic
latent semantic analysis
As an extension of PLSA for doing
contextual text mining.
Recall that in contextual text mining
we hope to analyze topics in text.
In consideration of context so that we
can associate the topics with
appropriate context that we're
interested in.
So in this approach contextual
probabilistic latent semantic
analysis or CPLSA
The main idea is to explicitly add
interesting context variables into a
generated model.
Recall that before when we generate the
text, we generally assume we will start
with some topics and then sample words
from some topics.
But here we are going to add context
variables so that the coverage of
topics and also the content of topics
will be tight little context.
Or in other words, we can do let the
context influence both coverage and
content of a topic.
The consequences that this would enable
us to discover contextualized topics
make the topics more interesting, more
meaningful, because we can then have
topics that can be interpreted as
specific to a particular context that
we're interested in.
For example, a particular time period.
As extension of PLSA model, CPLSA
mainly does the following changes.
Firstly it would model the conditional
likelihood of text given context.
That clearly suggests that the
generation of text would then depend on
context, and that allows us to bring
context into the generative model.
Secondly, it makes 2 specific
assumptions about the dependency of
topics on context.
One is to assume that depending on the
context depending on different time
periods or different locations, we
assume that there are different views
of the topic or different versions of
word distributions that characterize a
topic, and this assumption allows us to
discover different variations of the
same topic in different context.
The other is that we assume.
The topic coverage also depends on the
context.
And that means depending on the time or
location, we might cover topics
differently.
And then again this dependency would
then allow us to capture the
association of topics with specific
context.
We can still use the EM algorithm to
solve the problem of parameter
estimation.
And in this case, the estimate premise
would naturally contain context
variables, and in particular a lot of
conditional probabilities of topics
given certain context.
And this would allow us to do
contextual text mining.
So this is the basic idea.
Now we don't have time to introduce
this model in detail, but there are
references here that you can look into
to know more detail here.
I just want to explain the high level
ideas in more detail, particularly
willing to explain the generation
process of text data that has context
associated in such a model.
So as you see here, we can assume there
are still multiple topics.
For example, some topics might
represent the themes like a government
response donation or the city of New
Orleans.
Now this example is in the context of
Hurricane Katrina and that hit New Orleans.
Now, as you can see, we assume there
are different views associated with the
each of the topics.
And these are shown as view one, view two and
view three
Each view is a different version of
word distributions.
And these views are tide to some
context variables.
For example, type to the location Texas
or the time July 2005 or the occupation
of the other being sociologist.
Now on the right side you see now we assume the
document has contact information, so
the time is known to be July 2005,
location is Texas, etc.
Now such context information is what we
hope to model as well.
So we're not going to just model the
text.
And so one idea here is to model the
variations of topic content in
different context and this gives us
different views of the world
distributions.
Now on the bottom you will see the
theme coverage or topic coverage might
also vary according to these context.
Because in the.
In the case of location like Texas,
people might want to cover the red
topics more at the new audience, as
visualized here.
But in a certain time period, maybe
particular topic like donation will be
covered more so this variation is also
considered in CPLSA.
So to generate such a document with
context, we first also choose a view.
And this view of course now could be
from any of these contexts.
Let's say we have taken this view.
That depends on the time in the middle.
So now we have a specific version of
word distributions.
Now you can see some probabilities of
words for each topic.
Now, once we have chosen a view, now
the situation will be very similar to
what happened in standard PLSA.
We assume we have got a word
distribution associated with each
topic, right?
And then next to the view we choose a
coverage from the bottom.
So we're going to choose particular
coverage and that coverage.
Before is fixed in PLSA and it's hard to
a particular document.
Each document has just one coverage
distribution.
Now here, because we consider context
so the distribution of topics or the
coverage of topics can vary depending
on the context that has influenced the
coverage.
So, for example, we might pick a
particular coverage, let's say in this
case.
We pick
We've picked the document specifically
coverage now with the coverage and
these word distributions, we can
generate the document in exactly the
same way as in PLSA.
So what it means we're going to use the
coverage to choose a topic to choose
one of these three topics.
Let's say we have picked up, let's say,
the yellow topic, then withdraw a word
from this particular topic on the top.
So we might get the word
like government.
And then next time we might choose a
different topic, an will get donate,
etc right until we generate all the
words and this is basically the same
process as in PLSA.
Now, so the main difference is when we
obtain the coverage and the word
distributions, we let the context
influence our choice.
So in other words, we have extra
switches that are tied to this context
that would control the choices of
different views of topics and choices
of coverage.
And naturally, the model will have more
parameters to estimate, but once we can
estimate those parameters that involve
the context, then we will be able to
understand the context of
specific views of topics or context of
specific coverages of topics.
And this is precisely what we want in
contextual text mining.
So here are some sample results from
using such a model.
Not necessary exactly the same model,
but similar models.
So on this slide you see some sample
results of comparing news articles
about Iraq war and Afghanistan war.
Now we have about 30 articles.
On Iraq war and 26 articles on
Afghanistan war.
Now, in this case, the goal is to.
To review the common topics covered in
both sets, articles and the differences
or variations of the topic in each of the
two collections.
So in this case, the context that is
explicitly specified by the topical
collection.
And we see the results here show that.
There is a common theme that's
corresponding to cluster around here in
this column.
That there is a common theme indicating
that United Nations is involved in both
wars is a common topic covered in both
sets of articles, and that's indicated
by the high probability words shown here
United Nations.
Now if you the background, of course
this is not surprising and this is.
This topic is indeed very relevant,
to both wars.
If you look at the column further and
what's interesting is that the next two
cells of word distributions actually
tell US collection specific variations
of the topic of United Nations.
So it indicates that in Iraq war,
United Nations was more involved in
weapon inspections, whereas in
Afghanistan war it was more involved in
maybe aid to Northern Alliance as a
different variation of the topic of
United Nations.
So this shows that by bringing the
context, in this case, different wars
are different collections of text.
We can have topic variations, tied to
these contexts to review the
differences of coverage of United
Nations in the two wars.
Similarly, if you look at the second
cluster.
Cluster 2 has to do with the killing
of people and again.
Not surprising if you know the background
about wars or the wars involved
killing of people.
But imagine if you are not familiar
with the text collections or have a lot
of text articles and such a technique
can review the common topics covered in
both sets of articles.
It can be used to review common topics
in multiple sets of articles as well.
If you look down, of course in that
column of cluster 2 you see variations
of killing of people and that
correspond to in different different
contexts.
And here is another example of results.
Obtain the front block articles about
the Hurricane Katrina.
Now in this case, what you see here is
visualization of the.
trends of topics overtime.
And the top one shows just the temporal
chains of two topics.
One is oil price and one is.
about the flooding of the city.
New Orleans.
This these topics are obtained from
block articles about the Hurricane
Katrina.
And people talked about these topics.
And in addition to some other topics.
But the visualization shows that with
this technique that we can have
conditional distribution of time given
a topic.
So this allows us to plot this
conditional probability.
General curves like what you're seeing
here.
We see that initially the two curves
tracked each other very well. But later we see the topic of New Orleans was mentioned again but oil price was not
and
This turns out to be the time period
when another Hurricane Hurricane Rita
hit the region that apparently tricked
more discussion about the flooding of
the city.
The bottom curve shows the coverage of
this topic about the flooding of the
city by block articles in different
locations and also shows some shift of
coverage.
That might be related to peoples
migrating from the state of Louisiana
to Texas, for example.
So in this case we can see the time can
be used as context to reveal trends of
topics.
This is some additional result on
special patterns and this.
In this case it's about the topic of
government response.
And there was some criticism about the
slow response of government in the case
of Hurricane Katrina, and discussion
now is covered in different locations
and these visualizations show the
coverage in different weeks of the
event, and initially it's covered
mostly in the victim states in the
South, but then gradually it's
spreading to other.
Locations, but in week four, which is
shown on the bottom on the left, we see
a pattern that's very similar to the
very first week on the top left, and
that's why again the hurricane Rita
hit the region.
So such a technique would allow us to
use location as context to examine
variations of topics.
And of course, the model is completely
general, so you can apply this to any
other collections of text to reveal
spatial temporal patterns.
Is yet another application of this kind
of model where we look at the use of
the model for event impact analysis.
So here we are looking at the research
articles in information retrieval, IR,
particularly SIGIR papers.
And the topic we focus on is about
the retrieval models and you can see
the top word top words with high
probability is about this model on the
left.
And then we hope to examine the impact
of two events.
One is the start of TREC for text
retrieval conference.
This is a major evaluation effort
sponsored by US government and was
launched in 1992 or around that time
and that is known to have made an
impact on the topics of research
information retrieval.
The other is the publication of a
Seminal paper by Croft and Ponte, and
this is about the language modeling
approach to information retrieval.
It's also known to have made a high
impact on information retrieval
research, so we hope to use this kind
of model, understand impact, and the
idea here is simply to use the time as
context an use these events to divide
the time periods into a period before
the event an another after this event,
and then we can compare the differences
of.
The topics, the coverage and
variations, etc.
So in this case the results show I've
seen that before TREC the study of
retrieval models was mostly a vector
space model, Boolean model, etc.
But the after TREC.
Apparently the study of retrieval
models have involved a lot of other
words that seem to suggest some
different retrieval tasks though.
So for example email was used in the
enterprise search tasks and subtropical
retrieval, with another task introduced
later by
TREC.
On the bottom we see the variations
that are correlated with the
publication of the language model
paper.
Before we have those classical
probabilistic model logic model,
Boolean model etc.
But after 1998 that we see clear
dominance of language model as
probabilistic models and we see words
like a language model, estimation of
parameters etc.
So this technique here can use event as
context.
To understand the impact of event
again, the technique is general so you
can use this to analyze the impact of
any event.
Here are some suggested readings.
The first is
paper about simple extension of PLSA to
enable cross collection comparison.
It's to perform comparative text mining
to allow us to extract the common
topics shared by multiple collections
and their variations in each
collection.
The second one is the main paper about
the CPLSA model with a discussion of
a lot of applications.
The third one has a lot of details
about this special temporal patterns
for Hurricane Katrina, example.